it's a few days for Los Angeles and I
want to start by thanking the community
and the love that has poured out when FC
hustle we learned that another young
life was cut short by a gun in our city
and the pain of that in a city that's
experienced the safest decade in 10
years many measures the safest city in
America but a place still as I've always
said where one death is one too many
Nipsey Hussle was an artist who touched
our city and the lives far beyond of the
City of Angels throughout this country
and this world he was somebody who was a
gifted and brilliant artist an
entrepreneur who found global success
was working closely with this city to
help save lives and transform lives even
as he was doing that for himself he was
a tireless advocate for the young people
of this city and of this world to lift
them up with the possibility of not
being in prison by where you come from
or past mistakes but the possibility of
what comes in the future and his impact
on our city was deep you'll hear that
from the councilmember Marquess Harris
Dawson in a moment my own office was
able to work with him on a number of
initiatives to bring more
african-americans in the tech industry
to stand up businesses for people who
have been involved with the criminal
justice system and the news that we have
to share this morning is that the
hard-working men of the Los Angeles
Police Department together with the
strong relationships we have within the
community
have identified the person believed to
be responsible for this devastating
crime he is 29 year old Eric Holder and
in just a few moments we'll hear from
chief more he'll share some details
about that and ask for the public's help
in bringing justice to nipsey's family
and if anywhere out there has
information about this individual or
this crime we urge you to call LAPD's
South Bureau homicide at two one three
four eight five four three four
one nipsey's death has sent shockwaves
across the city and across this globe
but we're also here for all Angelenos
whose lives have been cut short as well
even though we see homicides down this
year-to-date by over 17% there have been
11 homicides throughout the city in the
last week alone 11 lives 11
possibilities 11 dreams 11 family
members 11 friends were cut short and
just because they didn't make the
headlines their loved ones are just as
deeply grieving as so many friends and
family are for nipsey these individuals
should still be here with us today fact
is there's been an uptick in violence
and shootings in South LA in the 77th
division in recent weeks we intend to
use the strength of this city to roll
that back a strength that isn't just
about badges and guns it is mostly about
first and foremost the strength of our
community relationships yes of course
with the police and from the police but
the churches the community groups the
neighbors our gang reduction in youth
development intervention workers and
prevention workers who know the names
after many years of work of people who
live and play in parks in these
neighborhoods who go to school in these
neighborhoods who are in there living in
these neighborhoods and I'm deeply
concerned and I will commit everything
this city has together with the county
and we're blessed to have supervisor
mark Willie Thomas here and the City
Council to turn this around I want to
thank the folks that are here as I
mentioned chief Moore councilmember
harris-dawson also councilmember Monica
Rodriguez who chairs our Public Safety
Committee Commission President Steve
Sabra and all the LAPD command staff and
officers community leaders that are here
with us today and amazing folks from our
grid teams all those intervention
workers who when the bullets fly go out
to the streets and run towards them
through the hard work and commitment of
these Angelenos and the strength of this
fabric which I'm so proud has available
for many years put together it's
stitched together in the
City to be an example for this nation
we've made extraordinary strides that
coalition has helped us get over 14,000
guns off our streets House helped us
bring in South LA the safest year in
recorded memory the lowest homicide
seconds lowest number of homicides
excuse me in 50 years in Los Angeles and
most importantly working hard to
strengthen relationships even further
councilmember harris-dawson myself
worked very hard to bring the community
safety partnership to Harvard Park once
seen as the deadliest place in Los
Angeles this is an assignment of five
years for officers so they can get to
know the names of people who are in that
neighborhood and vice versa and those
relationships have turned a corner in
Harvard Park in 2017 there were no
homicides three last year but that's way
down from what we saw a year over year
over year this is about young people of
color being able to have opportunities
in their lives maybe become police
officers themselves get to know those
who police with them and for them and
this is about hope for the future
we have a reason to feel hopeful even in
the moments of our most extreme pain and
that's by turning to each other we saw
that and we've seen that since nipsey
was taken from this that love that is
out there and I ask everybody who's
grieving for him degree for the families
of those other victims as well whose
lives were just as important and just as
significant what we see now is yet
another reason to be hopeful as this
coalition and the help the public can
give nipsey's family and the family of
those other homicide victims that at
least justice can be served and i would
say to anybody out there to the absolute
worst way to payback nipsey's loss
somebody we lost at the hands of
violence is with more violence and we
know that there is much more love than
hate much more love than violence out
there
we intend to give space for people to
grieve space for people to mourn it's
ways for people to come together right
now I want to turn it over to a man who
knew nipsey
worked very closely with him helped his
businesses gets stood up helped him to
make sure he was part of the
transformation this man is leading in
his district along Crenshaw Boulevard
and keeping african-american businesses
there helping young people have avenues
of success that we see in other parts of
town
I want to thank him I know his heart is
grieving and is heavy but please welcome
councilmember marquis harris-dawson
thank you so much mr. mayor and chief
and officers of the Los Angeles Police
Department and all the assembled elected
officials and community leaders that are
with us today we've lost in South Los
Angeles and extremely bright light over
this past weekend
Nipsey Hussle is a shining example of
the best of what we can be and the best
of what it means to seek and carry out a
redemptive charge this is a young man
who is the son and grandson of South Los
Angeles both from an immigrant family
and from a traditional african-american
family who saw much of the devastation
that we all recorded over the 1990s and
beyond
as a young person who witnessed this at
some point in his life he made the
decision that he was going to be part of
the solution and he was going to lead
the charge on the solution deciding and
taking a very firm stance that he lived
out that if South Los Angeles is to ever
have what it deserves if the community
is ever to be treated the way it should
be treated that we had to own and build
it for ourselves and he spent the last
half dozen years trying to carry out
that vision while he built a very
successful music career and so his gift
and his insistence on us living our best
life with from the highest level to
developing really three strong
organizations and businesses in South
Los Angeles to the lowest level and so
there were many occasions where I stood
with him on that very parking lot and
was fascinated by the fact that the
small business owner next door knew him
by first name as well as the person
struggling with addiction or
homelessness knew him by his first name
and watched him grow up and so it is a
dear loved one that we have lost and a
demonstration of the very brutal array
that none of us are safe until all of us
are safe
one of nipsey's most well known songs
says bullets don't have names and as
long as they're flying all of us are in
danger and so we continue to celebrate
his legacy and we ask the community to
do so in a way that is consistent with
his story consistent with his gift and
consistent with his promise at the same
time I would also echo the comments of
the mayor and I know the chief will talk
about this later we have an uptick of
violence in South Los Angeles gun
violence in particular again it is not
off the chart or it is not like things
that we've seen in years past certainly
not in decades pass but nipsey is an
example for all of us that any life lost
is a life too many and so we ask
everybody to work together to stand
together and to fight together to create
the kind of streets and communities that
we deserve to live in where people can
live out their highest and best
potentials thank you all so much thank
you so much councilmember next I'd like
my supervisor mark ridley-thomas to step
forward who's been one of the first
people in this city when he served on
the City Council to work on those
intervention and prevention programs
that are part of that fabric and he is
one of the strongest threads in this
city mark ridley-thomas thank you very
much mr. mayor
the councilman to achieve in the
commission president I'm simply here on
behalf the County of Los Angeles
collaborating with the city of Los
Angeles to declare that we pursue
justice at the same time we embrace
peace it seems to me that the uptick in
violence is it has been referenced is
intolerable and it's no point into
trying to minimize its impact anytime
it strikes it seems to me that we have
to be vigilant in our pushback and I
think we have to be imaginative and then
regard through traditional police
methodologies but also through enhanced
methods that are time-tested in terms of
community involvement and that's
essentially what will make the ultimate
difference we have to do more the County
of Los Angeles in collaboration with the
city of Los Angeles sets that as its
goal and objective the Department of
Public Health recognized the uptick and
violence to be a matter of its concern
therefore the establishment of the
office of violence prevention and this
office is designed to do
not only prevention but treatment for
those who are the loved ones of homicide
victims and other victims of violence
that don't result in fatalities so today
it seems to me that it's very very
important for us to make it clear that
we will be increasingly proactive in
this regard the Health Department is
extending its hours beyond the ordinary
hours of closing at 4:00 all the way to
seven to ensure support for anyone who
was in need never underestimate the
trauma that is inflicted on families and
communities pursuant to violence the
issue of gun violence cannot be
minimized the teach we preach we
practice the notion controlling this
phenomenon now it seems to me we have
yet another opportunity to accelerate in
terms of what our commitments are and so
this coming Friday the fifth will be
more announcements in this regard that
were frankly already in place prior to
this tragic death that we focus on today
but essentially to say that our work is
cut out for us and we will not strength
we will step up to the responsibility to
pursue more violence prevention in our
communities
starting with
the area that is often described the
South Los Angeles where the problem is
persistent and we cannot ignore that
reality our obligation is to face to
address it and do so with all of our
capacity thank you very kindly
thank you very much supervisor to
leaders in Public Safety one who
oversees our City Council Public Safety
Committee as I mentioned Monica
Rodriguez and we thank her for her
leadership and being here and the
president of our Police Commission the
civilians that oversee our department
salute and then chief Moore will give
you details and ask for some help as
well and then we'll answer any question
so I chairwoman Thank You mayor and as
been stated we all grieve right now with
the tragic circumstances around nipsey's
loss of life but we don't also forget
the individuals that have also been lost
as a result of the tragic violence that
has occurred on our streets whether in
South Los Angeles or any other part in
the city of Los Angeles it's really
important that we as a community come
together and not come back with violence
it's important that we help collaborate
with the Los Angeles Police Department
it was through the collaboration of the
community and our local police officers
that we were able to apprehend suspects
in a case in my district but so often
families are not getting the justice
that they deserve in apprehending the
perpetrators of the crimes throughout
the city so it is incredibly important
that everyone in the community find an
opportunity to communicate with LAPD to
build that relationship and to share the
information that they do know so that we
can apprehend the perpetrators of these
horrific crimes and that more families
in our city don't have to suffer the
tragic consequences of loss there's
often opportunities for each of us to
play a role and we invite you to be part
of how we assure the safety in our
streets so that we do not lose any more
of our children or any one more member
of our families and we invite you to be
a partner with us with the los angeles
de piel police department and the city
cal
so that we can assure that we create the
kind of environments in our communities
that we will all be proud of that we
will remain a safe city and it's
important that everybody play a hand in
cooperatively working with us to help
create an environment that we will all
be proud of creating that safe Street
environment for our kids and giving them
the opportunities to achieve their
fullest potential thank you so I had a
personal experience it was quite sad
quite upsetting and quite angry and I
went through my emails yesterday and I
found the original email requesting from
nipsey and rock nation requesting to me
to set up meeting with the chief and I'm
gonna read it to you
this was dated February February 26th
our goal is to ascend to me
our goal is to work with the department
to help improve communication
relationships and work towards changing
the culture and dialogue between LAPD
and the inner city we want to hear about
your new programs your goals for the
department as well as how we can help
stop gang violence and help you help
kids so takes time to set up meetings we
did was set up 4:30 yesterday and chief
called me on Sunday and told me this was
15 minutes after that the Nipsey Hussle
had been assassinated
I was ready for the meeting I was
excited about the meeting here was uh
somebody coming in to say how can we
help
how could we be a partner so Sunday
morning I took out my clothes for Monday
Save the Children tie it's all ready to
go and then I got the Chiefs call and
then I started getting other calls I put
out a note out of respect saying that in
here this horrible thing happened one
day before every we have this meeting
why couldn't we have had the meeting
that day before instead the day after
and you get 10 12 people criticized put
to date on the email people that have
gotten contact looked at this believe in
in building bridges 4 million people 4
million 15,000 people so the meeting
will happen it will happen when the wind
rock nation and his family will come
together and I promise you whether from
the upper levels of this or from the
bottom level of this that I want to help
do what he wanted to do
and he wanted us to do that and so did
these 4 million people who have
contacted me
finally chief Moore will brief the
context about this killing as well as
crime in South Los Angeles right now
particularly in 77th division and nearby
and then we'll answer your questions
chief take it mr. mayor
supervisor council marqueece
harris-dawson councilman Rodriguez
community and faith leaders that are
with us today our command staff we
joined as does all of the Los Angeles
and a somber day in the aftermath of a
senseless another senseless homicide an
individual who posed such an opportunity
to step into a conversation to help this
city work its way through a sickness a
challenge a seemingly tragic love affair
with gun violence today's conversation
is a broader context because I'll
there's moments in time that you have as
individuals whether it be cheap for a
police officer or remember the media or
faith leaders that you look down on a
message or you hear a call and you just
find it so like you take his second
guess or you say I take a second look
sunday afternoon was that for me sunday
afternoon this department in the last
three months had seen an error where
last year we saw the second fewest
number of homicides in the city in more
than 50 years we saw enough reduction
and overall violent aunt part one crime
we saw 35 fewer gang-related homicides
and 59 fewer gang-related shootings but
yet as I had reported approximately two
to three weeks ago we began seeing an
increase in gang-related violence and in
shooting violence that was starting to
trend in a manner
that was causing us concerns and as an
organization that looks at safety across
this community each day and works to
align its resources to identify those
locations that need us most
and we partner with our community
coalition's the Watts gang task force I
was yesterday at the Baptist ministers
conference and our grid event
intervention prevention resources Sunday
afternoon we had those all in play
because we had seen a week of violence
that even took what we'd saw in the
first couple weeks of March to a higher
level pretty clean in South Los Angeles
that's Wednesday we met with the
Coalition where we talked about while
we've seen an overall reduction in
violence still fewer homicides more than
three hundred fewer shooting three
hundred fewer victims of violent crime
we have seen a recent increase in
shooting violence in South Los Angeles
in 77th and particularly impacting
african-american men and it was causing
us growing concerns and we needed those
coalition's those faith leaders those
those members of the public that are
working to be peacemakers in our
communities we need them to step forward
and Monday while I was not picking out
my clothes on Sunday I generally wear a
pretty pre-design outfit that but on
Sunday I was looking forward to the
Monday conversation because yet it was
another opportunity for this department
to find Brown in which from strategies
and advocates and people in our
community that could step into a
conversation of how to stem this
violence today we still are below our
all-time highs
but Nipsey Hussle represents the
enormity of the lives that we have lost
and I felt as I looked at that message
from LA fire that told me we have three
additional shooting victims that had
just occurred at Slauson in crunch
and I began that message as I was
reading it standing on the street
exactly where I was at and then I saw
the name Nipsey Hussle and I looked at
that again and I looked at it again and
it was like you oh I could not believe
it it was like it just drove the added
violence even that much more severe so I
have devastated with that because this
is a voice that could that was trying to
help it was investing in his community
but I'm also here with an error because
on that Sunday earlier that morning I
was at my wife the new Christian
Memorial Church in Pacoima where senior
pastor Sandra Croce stands as a bulwark
of peace and a finding community safety
and I'm encouraged by that message that
Sunday morning of renew and of not
giving up and finding hope and today I'm
going to talk momentarily about where
we're at on this investigation of this
the man we believe responsible for the
killing of mr. hustle but I'm also
encouraged by what's happened since the
shooter what has continued over the
weekend and into this morning and that
is the community coalition's the Watts
gang task force cocoa the Nation of
Islam faith leaders committee advocates
grid and grid interventionist
Prevention's have stepped up on doubled
to not allow this to be hijacked by an
individual who would want to exact
further violence I am also thankful for
the men and women of LAPD who have done
on a parallel course they have
investigated this and aggressively with
relentlessly utilizing witness
statements video evidence criminal crime
scene investigation and we have
identified at this point based on what
we know the individual we believe
responsible and I'm going to provide
that information
but simultaneously our men and women
have been in our communities not just on
this shooting violence in this homicide
but other violence in 77th and there
South Los Angeles to try to quell
further acts and they have been so while
facilitating a vigil on what I believe
is sacred ground and and last night as
we saw the night before with such
emotions and such high intensity of
people grieving we can see instances in
which turmoil or altercations or fights
will erupt and I'm proud of the men and
women of my department working with our
faith and community leaders who have who
have facilitated those and at the same
time that their best work to provide for
the safety and last night was most
recent example and today we have
redoubled and gone back out this again
to have this a community led vigil and
for those that would attend now and in
the future I just ask for you to bring
peace bring peace and not allow this
this is sacred ground to be the site of
any further violence now regarding we're
at on the homicide and the tragic death
of Missy we provided a press account
last night following our investigative
efforts we are currently working with
the District Attorney's Office to seek
the necessary information to obtain a
warrant for his arrest but we believe
with probable cause and degree of
certainty that on Sunday at about 3:20
in the afternoon Nipsey with two other
males were standing in front of his
store as it has been reported that mr.
hole walked up on more on multiple
occasions and engaged in a conversation
with if she and the others that were
there he left and then came back and
Cecily came back armed with a handgun
and purposely is repeatedly fired
striking and killing Nipsey Hussle
as well as striking and injuring that
the other two one requiring them to be
hospitalized or transported to a nearby
hospital the other suffering alone but
was treated at scene mr. holder we have
identified him through at this point the
video available video evidence a
statement and information that we're
getting from our community and I cannot
think enough that the community is the
one who is helping us solve this case as
in every case it is a community's
engagement that makes our lives safer
that provides justice for these victims
and their families mr. holder entered
the passenger side of a 2016 Chevy Cruze
it's a white four-door vehicle this
license plate is 7 Robert John David
that's our JD 742 and the vehicle was
driven by an unidentified woman and that
was that vehicle was located in the
alley adjacent to that mini-malls trip
center where it fled from the scene we
have as mayor indicated we continue to
seek the public's help and assistance to
fold people that were at that scene or
have information from people who were at
that scene that can help identify
further and provide this evidence of the
persons responsible for this senseless
murder we ask that you call our South
Carroll homicide detectives day or night
you also can use we tip and Crime
Stoppers and report anonymously we're
not done in gathering evidence on this
horrific shooting secondarily
is we want the public to help us
identify and apprehend mr. Holden armed
with a handgun the senseless murder this
expression of violence represents that
this is a man who is of a substantial
risk to public safety and willing to use
violence and we want to see that stop
and we need the public's help in
identifying him and do mr. holder who I
am confident is watching this and it's
listening to these media accounts as
this is spread not only around
Rhegium to run around this world I ask
him to surrender to find a law or local
law enforcement agency to go to a
station and surrender and to represent
to defend himself as he feels
appropriate but to stop this mess to
stop this from continuing let me comment
just briefly and in regards to the the
context of this increase in violence so
January in February of this year the
city averaged approximately 13 shooting
victims a week and that number may sound
high is actually for a law science
police department in all city of of
Angels it was at and below last year's
numbers and the year before substantial
March we saw that number doubled to 26
on average and nearly entirely that
increase was in 77th area of the South
Los Angeles 37th in January and February
experienced just under five shootings a
week that number expanded to nearly 15
on average a week in the month of March
much of it is getting back nearly all of
it is gang-related
Nipsey Hussle x' death and his tragic
shooting I have no information today
that has that involved in this other
shooting violence and that needs to be
stressed what we're seeing here is not
just a shooting of a hip-hop artist a
profound individual coming back to give
back to his community what I'm concerned
about as chief and I know our community
leaders are as well is we've got to
continue to go at this recent increase
in shooting violence because it's not
just a dispute over a personal matter
this is gang violence that we're seeing
particularly in South Los Angeles but
also on the Westside and in other parts
of city that we need to redouble our
efforts and keep working towards
intervening and finding ways of
resolving disputes
without people resulting to a bullet
with no name on it so with that I'm
we're the group were here to answer
questions and concerns and I remind as
the mayor have indicated that there's a
as we focused a lot of effort and energy
and his remarks today in our remarks
that this still remains one of the
safest times in Los Angeles but we don't
reach that safety by apathy or
minimizing what we have in front of us
each of these lives matter and our
commitment as a department am I elected
our elected officials who aren't proud
of their work and investment our
community and faith leaders is that
we're relentless and we will not give up
and seeing that our communities are safe
thank you at this point also I know
there's Spanish media of what most are
questions answers to also statement
Spanish at the end or Spanish may be
good so at this point our investigation
based on witness statements and the
background of those that we've
identified we believe this to be a
dispute between mr. hustle and mr.
holder I'm not going to going to the
conversations but it appears to be a
personal matter between the two of them
and regards to dispute and now I'll
leave it at that we I'm gonna ask you to
understand that we have identified mr.
holder because based on today based on
yes we actually yesterday what we've
learned in the first 24 hours we believe
him to be the responsible individual for
this killing and I have responsibility
we have responsibility as law
enforcement to work and ensure that the
public's made aware of that as well as
our officers and other law enforcement
who may come across this individual
who's armed with a handgun and willing
to use such violence we're working
closely with district attorney's office
and I do not wish to prejudice this case
or undermine its success by going into
too much detail relative to the facts
and circumstances
again they are known we believe they
were known to each other we here two
women showed up in hospitals that had
been shot so let me clarify let me talk
about what we know today about the
events of last night so the vigils I was
at that scene yesterday I'm proud of the
work again of our of our interventions
and prevention or faith leaders that
were there to orchestrate and support
and kind of organize that that
spontaneous vigil and the conduct of
other the vast majority of people was
well they were grieving and they're
trying to struggle through that about a
little after eight o'clock last night it
appears based on the information we have
today that an individual in the crowd
was armed with a handgun that he
produced that handgun as a means of
displaying it or brandishing it or
showing it we have no information that
he meant to that we have no official
right now that he shot anyone with it
but then another individual they're
seeing that and recognizing the danger
of that attempted to disarm him and in
that struggle that caused Asli panic in
that group of hundreds of people and a
cascade or stampede if you will people a
step expecting hoping to leave and
enough is up for any injury as they fled
that location we have a series of Falls
and trips and injuries from the glass
and other materials that were there and
that was the vast majority of the
injuries that we saw were cut injuries
from Falls sprains ankles and so forth
we did have one individual who
reportedly was stabbed they do not have
they do not have any description of who
they believe stabbed up and we're
operating that that's a stabbing
occurred and we'll continue to
investigate that later about 11 o'clock
last night we have two women who arrived
at a hospital initially reported a
different location an account man stated
that they had been shot they later then
articulated that they were at the vigil
when the shooting occurred
we had a commander on scene
the event when this event unfolded that
was fifty feet away from where the vigil
was occurring and we do not have any
report of gunfire being heard we will
continue to investigate the nature of
the injuries the two women suffered I'm
not questioning their account but at
this point I am I'm lacking information
that a shooting occurred what is
critical and I'm so thankful again is a
conduct of restraint by our officers who
took a number of bottles we had a
sergeant that took sutures to his hand
from a serious cut of items that were
thrown in the police
our officers exercised tremendous
restraint and worked closely with with
various representatives of the community
and coalition's to establish and
reestablish control and the safety of
the people that were there over the
night we have worked with Tony Muhammad
from initiative Islam with our mayor's
crisis response team with MS Trembley
from the mayor's office grid and faith
leaders to clean that area to set to
remove the trash and debris to package
or safeguard the items of memorial that
were not damaged for the family and to
establish reestablish again a process in
which people who wish to visit visit
that memorial that vigil are allowed to
do so in an organized manner the Police
Department will remain in the area our
officers will remain on standby but I
began I'm proud of the work of our
community activists and organizers as
they organize and administer allow LA to
grieve and really people from across the
country have have responded this
location or effort to pay their respect
and we hope to see that last night is
the last night of any touch of instance
that we saw
yes we do believe the driver of the
vehicle is we're very interested in
identifying and apprehending that
individual investigating their
involvement and their culpability for
this murder I'm gonna say yes at this
point do any public announcement I want
to make is that these two individuals
mr. holder and then the female that was
driving the vehicle that afforded him
the escape from the location our primary
interest but I would caution anyone that
would give mr. holder or they have them
they know the identity of that driver
and with aid and abet them from being
found we will pursue and vigorously
prosecute them for that harboring there
is should be no safe haven for this
individual he poses an imminent risk to
public safety as well as should face
addresses in regards to his actions
well I'm not going there's there's a
turn of phrase when you say gang related
gang motivated we know mr. hustles has
represented his earlier involvement and
membership with with with a street gang
in Los Angeles we believe mr. holder is
a member of a street gang I'm not going
to identify street gangs by name that I
don't believe that that is an
appropriate thing for for a law
enforcement professional to do or
executive but the aspect of the nature
of this view is not to our information
anything relative to rivalries between
gangs but rather dispute between these
two individuals so I'm going to limit
our remark will provide more information
as it develops as to his background
again I want to the most important thing
is his identity and to locate in that
for him him I wish to provide him every
fair right to due process and so forth
and I'm not going to paint him any
fashion beyond what I've described
well the moment this shooting occurred
the persons responsible know who they
were they knew they knew of their
involvement whether or not their
understanding of our understanding
influenced their flight or if they even
did if they even have fled the area is
of interest to me but my primary issue
is we will provide for both
contingencies if they're if they are
fled we will pursue whether they are
here locally or they have gone other
locations I appreciate the media's
efforts of stressing to the all of our
communities both locally in otherwise
then if we know where this man is at or
the driver of that vehicle please
contact LAPD so we may go out and fight
for his arrest we have one more
yes
so we're we're very aware of the use of
social media today by all by a number of
parties if we saw the horrific attacks
in New Christchurch New Zealand where a
gunman used social media livestream such
a horrific attack we know that those
that are involved in these types of this
type of violence has a certain perverse
sickness where they use social media as
a platform the legitimacy as you
identify is sometimes in question but
let me just be clear we are using every
investigative tool every
constitutionally afforded tool for us to
use an access social media to identify
the person responsible and I encourage
public however to use a skeptical eye an
ear when they look at social media and
they try to garner the facts or
circumstances because it is filled with
misinformation thank you